bienvenidos de nuevo cuando termine el
vídeo anterior iba un poco a las
carreras pero llegamos a la conclusión
de que si tengo digamos esta especie de
sube y baja verdad está este está este
plano de digamos no se puede ser de
madera apoyado sobre este digamos
triangulito y en este punto definimos lo
que era el fulcro entonces si teníamos
esta imagen digamos del sube y baja como
el de aquí y además conozco las
distancias desde la fuerza que aplicamos
al fulcro y desde el fulcro hasta donde
la máquina aplica la fuerza entonces
podemos conocer la relación que hay
entre estas dos fuerzas verdad y de
hecho decíamos que la fuerza digamos la
fuerza de entrada multiplicada por esta
distancia es igual a la fuerza de salida
por la distancia del fulcro a donde se
aplica esa fuerza y esencialmente lo
determinamos a partir de la ley de la
conservación de la energía donde
decíamos además que realmente el trabajo
que se generaba o algo similar
o podríamos decir que la transferencia
de energía que había desde donde
aplicamos la fuerza era igual a la
transferencia de energía pero de salida
verdad entonces vamos a utilizar todos
estos principios para resolver un par de
ejemplos digamos que tenemos digamos que
tenemos aquí nuevamente una especie de
sube y baja muy bien y aquí tenemos este
un digamos aquí está nuestro fulcro
ahí lo tienen
está aquí apoyándose y digamos vamos a
tener una un cuerpo que tiene un peso de
100 newtons y recordemos que el peso es
una fuerza verdad supongan también que
tenemos que bueno solo podemos aplicar
una fuerza de 10 newtons muy bien solo
podemos aplicar una fuerza de diez
minutos digamos no sé a lo mejor estamos
limitados porque nosotros no podemos
aplicar más de 10 minutos ahora nosotros
sabemos que cuál es la relación entre
estas dos fuerzas verdad ahora la
pregunta sería donde debería yo poner el
fulcro de tal suerte que estos 10
newtons que yo puedo aplicar levanten
estos 100 newtons que tiene este cuerpo
de peso muy bien entonces lo que
nosotros sabemos es que es justamente la
relación que teníamos aquí esta fuerza
digamos de entrada que son 10 newtons en
mi ponerlo con el color que va los 10
newtons si nosotros lo multiplicamos por
la distancia de 2 que en este caso sería
de 2 aquí
y vamos a ponerle vamos vamos a ponerle
mejor de él de entrada la distancia que
corresponde a la entrada ya está la
distancia de salida entonces 10 newtons
que es la fuerza de entrada por la
distancia correspondiente debe ser igual
a los 100 newtons a los 100 newtons por
la distancia de salida muy bien entonces
si nosotros dividimos de ambos lados
entre 10 newtons tendremos que la
distancia de entrada debe ser igual a
100 newtons entre 210 newtons son
exactamente 10 newtons verdad entonces
son 10 newtons por la distancia de
salida
muy bien nos está diciendo que está
distancia de digamos donde aplicamos la
fuerza al fulcro debe ser 10 veces la
distancia
aquí los newton se cancelaban verdad si
newtons entre newton se cancelaban este
derecho no aparecía ok entonces lo que
nos queda es 10 veces la distancia de
salida es decir esta distancia de aquí
esta distancia y debe ser 10 veces la
distancia s muy bien entonces por
ejemplo si esta distancia s fuera de 5
metros quiere decir que la distancia
debe ser de 50 metros verdad
estos son los 50 metros y aquí por
supuesto no es que no es que estemos
reduciendo el o más bien multiplicando
la fuerza verdad nosotros aplicamos 10
newtons de fuerza y de repente salieron
100 newtons en realidad para poder hacer
esto hay que pagar cierto precio y eso
es porque tenemos que aplicar esta
fuerza de 10 newtons 10 veces esa
distancia de verdad entonces
aquí esencialmente nada es espontáneo el
trabajo de entrada debe ser igual al
trabajo de salida no no no podemos decir
que hay alguna máquina mágica que pueda
multiplicar el trabajo o la fuerza de la
nada si existiera bueno no habría que
estudiar esto y mejor nos ponemos a
fabricar estas máquinas y hacernos
millonarios pero todas las máquinas
esencialmente o al menos idealmente
trabajan de esta forma con esta relación
y en y en la mayoría de ellas siempre
hay una pérdida de freaks de trabajo
debido a la fricción entonces vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo digamos ahora que
tenemos otro sube y baja que digamos
ahora que tenemos una especie de sube y
baja de esta forma aquí tenemos un
pulcro ok
digamos aquí está el suelo entonces aquí
más o menos termina muy bien y digamos
que nosotros aplicamos una fuerza de 7
newtons aquí muy bien tenemos una fuerza
de 7 newtons
y supongamos que tenemos aquí 5 metros y
de este otro lado 35 metros 35 metros
ahora la pregunta es cuál es la fuerza
que puede o cuál es el peso que puede
soportar este este diagrama este esta
esta palanca digamos entonces lo que
nosotros sabemos es que 7 newtons 7
newtons por la distancia que en este
caso son 35 metros debe ser igual a 5
metros verdad por la fuerza que puede
soportar por esta digamos el peso de
este de este objeto
ok digamos que tiene una fuerza efe muy
bien entonces si nosotros dividimos
entre 5 metros de ambos lados que es lo
que vamos a tener entonces nuestra
fuerza digamos de salida la fuerza de
salida será igual a 7 newtons por 35
metros entre 5 metros eso nos da
simplemente 7 newtons
35 en 35 que son siete verdad siete por
cinco son 35 y estos son 49 newtons muy
bien entonces si nosotros tenemos
o más bien si nosotros queremos elevar
un metro del lado izquierdo en realidad
hay que aplicar la fuerza por digamos 7
metros 7 metros por la derecha para que
esto se lleve a cabo ahora en el próximo
vídeo hablaremos de otras máquinas como
las poleas y vamos a seguir trabajando
con esto de la ventaja mecánica nos
vemos pronto